this vulnerable world needs something
more powerful than any of us
everyone creates the thing they dread
Ultron in the flesh
no matter who wins or loses trouble
always comes around
you metal do something you don't
understand we have no face
I'm gonna tear you apart
five
Oh
you
hey youtubers what's up so this is gonna
be a breakdown to the New Avengers
footage I'm also running a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so here we go let's tear
this apart so most of the action of this
trailer is them in sokovia that's like
the fictional country where the movie
takes place it's like somewhere in the
Eastern Bloc so they're there in Europe
in this movie the voiceover from Tony
Stark just highlights the reason for
creating Ultron the Avengers themselves
can't handle all the Hydra clean up like
all the crap that's been going on since
Winter Soldier here we see a nice shot
of the new Captain America outfit we've
seen it in the previous trailer but this
is actually just a much better shot just
a slight tweak on the classic uniform I
wasn't a big fan of his uniform in the
first Avengers movie so I'm glad that
they changed it Hawkeye is uniform way
better - I like James Spader's line
everyone creates the thing that they
dread I'm sure this is gonna make a lot
of new parents happy when they see this
movie so the Nick Fury line trouble
always comes back around cut with the
Hulk scenes explain a little bit about
what's going on with Hulk in this film
there's always the battle between banner
and the big green guy but the
interesting thing that Mark Ruffalo has
said is that you know in this movie
they'll explore more of what's going on
in the green guy's head than in banners
head which i think is kind of
interesting it's just the idea that the
Hulk is just as afraid of banner as
banner is of the Hulk I know a lot of
people are wondering what samuel
l.jackson is actually doing in this
movie I mean he left after Winter
Soldier and turned over directorship of
shield to Coulson eventually he'll take
over again but I mean for the meantime
he's off running around with the
Avengers all over the world trying to
clean up this is one of the new unknown
characters they've been a lot of
theories about in humans as well as
Wakanda stuff my guess is it's more
tight so that Wakanda stuff that they're
trying to set up but it would make sense
that they would try to weave in this
Inhumans theme just to be more
consistent across the film I don't want
to speculate right away that it's
someone related to Black Panther but I
do think it's someone tied to Wakanda
just because of all the Andy Serkis talk
as well as Black Panther in the future
films let me know in the comments who do
you think that she is so we get a better
look at Scarlet Witch this looks like
it's early on before she actually joins
the Avengers because she's totally
giving it to Iron Man this scene of
these weird medical tools gets much
creepier it's possible they use black
widows brainwaves to create something or
they use her
in some way to create something there's
a lot of females tied to Ultron in the
comics you have Janet Van Dyne who was
in love with for a while and then you
have Jocasta who was supposed to be his
future bride
so these robots these are actually the
Ultron replicants this will be his army
that he sends out india circus here we
still haven't got confirmation whether
or not he's actually playing ulysses
klaw it's possible but he seems like
he's involved with Ultron somehow but
he's playing a villain we know he's a
villain in the movie there's just a big
connection between those two characters
in the comics as well as vibranium the
metal that Ultron might be using to make
himself stronger and it would also be an
easy into Black Panther into the Black
Panther character who actually won't
debut til Captain America Civil War this
longer version of the Hulk Black Widow
scene just implies that they have a
really deep connection in the movie it
seems like he's been using her as an
anchor for stability for mental
stability or for balance at least so
this is actually probably the coolest
shot in the trailer
Ultron with his energy beam he has
energy beams in the comics but it looks
like an alternate version of Thor's
lightning part of Ultron's modus
operandi is outdoing the Avengers so
naturally he would have some sort of
counter-attack for each of the Avengers
abilities I just love how creepy that
James Spader voice-over is I'm gonna
tear you apart from the inside that's
like something that the serial killer
would whisper to you on the bus this is
just a much longer Hulkbuster scene we
just get to see him drag him all over
town I'm interested to see what the
trigger is that sets banner off and if
it has something to do with the mind gem
again if you remember the original
Avengers film it's the the negative
mental energy that gets amplified by the
gem that makes them go nuts it's not
just the gem by itself like it's the gem
working with negative emotion what's
actually really cool about all this Hulk
stuff is that Andy Serkis worked a lot
with Mark Ruffalo about you know making
the Hulk an actual person I mean he is a
person it's all mopey but Andy Serkis is
the best mocap person on the planet so I
would feel like when they're shooting
scenes like this he has the same level
of authority that Joss Whedon would have
so that's pretty much it like the the
real question is you know who is that
new mystery character is she one of the
Inhumans since we got the reveal on
agents of shield like the Inhumans are
officially a thing in the Marvel
Universe now I was really surprised they
debuted that on the TV show the
film I think we'll explain that a little
bit better and then the TV show will run
with it they will be crossing over
agents of shield will cross over with
Avengers age of Ultron they'll at least
be an Avenger on shield there's still
some question about which TV actor is
gonna be in the film and I think it'll
probably a small cameo so my big
question for you guys is is you know
based on the last two trailers that
we've seen and I'll link the last one in
the description below let me know what
are you most excited about in this movie
I mean just the big action stuff like
the Hulkbuster hope vs. Hulkbuster
watching Ultron upgrade himself or
learning how the vision is created
that's my biggest question right now is
what is the impetus by which the vision
is created and it does it have something
to do with the Black Widow it's just in
the comics like when Ultron was created
for instance it takes someone like a
human's brain waves and then the same
thing happens for the vision like they
need an actual person's brain waves
before they can create the Android so in
case you haven't seen it I just posted
my top 5 Ultron stories from the comics
you can click here to watch that right
now and you can click here to catch up
on agent Carter before tomorrow there's
gonna be a new episode thank you so much
for watching let's all high-five I will
see you guys tomorrow
you